bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat comment faire de
l'école un foyer de transmission des
valeurs républicaines
la question se pose avec une résonance
toute particulière au lendemain des
attentats de janvier dernier alors dès
la fin janvier
une commission d'enquêté a été créée au
sénat à la demande du groupe ump
elle porte sur le service public de
l'éducation la perte de repères
républicains et les difficultés
rencontrées par les enseignants cette
commission recevait ce matin alain
gérard slama vous propose de revoir
cette audition le journaliste et
enseignant à sciences po est aussi
l'auteur d'un rapport en 2009 sur
l'éducation civique devant les sénateurs
il revient sur cet enseignement qu'il
voudrait le plus transversale possible
est enseignée dès le plus jeune âge
il appelle aussi les sénateurs à
s'interroger sur les notions les valeurs
transmises par l'école ententes ont tous
la même chose quand on parle fraternité
laïcité ou égalité je vous laisse
découvrir tout de suite son diagnostic
et ses propositions mes chers collègues
nous débutons aujourd'hui nos auditions
en recevant monsieur alain gérard slama
journaliste et enseignant l'institut
d'études politiques de paris comme le
bureau de la commission denquête l'a
décidé cette audition sera capté et
diffusé en direct sur le site internet
du sénat
elle fera également l'objet d'un compte
rendu publié dans le recueil des travaux
des commissions accessible en version
papier et sur le site internet du sénat
agrégé de lettres classiques vous êtes
éditorialiste au figaro chroniqueur aux
hebdomadaires le figaro magazine le
point et aux matins de france culture
vous travaillez notamment sur les
questions politiques sociales et
sociétales spécialiste des institutions
vous est notamment intéressé à l'une
d'entre elles celle qui nous intéresse
l'école en février 2003 vous avez ainsi
été nommé expert auprès de la commission
mise en place par le ministre de la
jeunesse
de l'éducation nationale et de la
recherche luc ferry et par le ministre
délégué à l'enseignement scolaire des
avis et darcos afin de rédiger un guide
destiné à faire vivre l'idée
républicaine dans les écoles la même
année vous participez aux travaux de la
commission nationale du débat sur
l'avenir de l'école qui a remis un
rapport au premier ministre en octobre
2004 proposant notamment la mise en
place d'un socle commun de connaissance
une meilleure formation des enseignants
et une éducation du citoyen en 2009
en votre qualité de membre du conseil
économique social et environnemental
vous signez un rapport sur l'éducation
civique à l'école dans lequel vous
proposiez d'asseoir les bases de
l'éducation civique dès la maternelle et
les premières années de l'enseignement
primaire de promouvoir un socle commun
de valeurs et de faire de l'enseignement
d'éducation civique un enseignement
transversal
c'est assez différent titre que la
commission denquête a souhaité vous
auditionnés nous aimerions avoir votre
avis sur la transmission des repères
républicain et sur le rôle que doivent
jouer les cols avant de vous passer la
parole le formalisme des commission
denquête me conduit à vous demander de
prêter serment
je suis également tenus de vous indiquer
que tout faux témoignage devant notre
commission serait passible des peines
prévues aux articles 434 13 à 434 15 du
code pénal en conséquence je vous invite
à prêter serment de dire toute la vérité
rien que la vérité levé la main droite
et dix jours je vous remercie
selon l' usage habituel je vous propose
de nous faire part de vos observations
durant une dizaine de minutes après quoi
notre rapporteur jacques grosperrin et
les membres de la commission qui le
souhaitent pour vous poser leurs
questions
je vous remercie j danse mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
rapporteur
vous avez pris de bien belle initiative
car il est extrêmement rare que des gens
autant boca s'adressent à d'autres
interlocuteurs que soient mes étudiants
de sciences pour devant lesquels j'ai
sévit plus largement plus de tort de 30
ans ce qui n'est pas peu dire
au poids que peut être certains d'entre
eux aujourd'hui de ne plus du tout envie
d'entendre le discours
et puis j'ai d'autre part évidemment les
lecteurs ou les auditeurs guide ne se
manifeste en général que selon du sage
que lorsqu'ils sont mécontents et donc
avoir enfin un contact avec des élus qui
auront eu de prise sur les choses est de
plus en plus parce qu'aujourd'hui le
parlement existe de plus en plus quoi
qu'on en dise et le sénat je suis des
premiers à être son groupe est aussi
vous m'autorisez parler franglais
c'est évidemment pour moi une chance
c'est presque une aubaine cela dit j'ai
écouté j'ai écouté tout
enfin grand nombre d interventions
précédentes et j'ai été frappé par
quelque part quelque chose notamment la
journée que vous avez consacré trois
ministres et ce qui m'a frappé c'était
confus où ils étaient très
complémentaires que de monsieur
chevènement à mon ami luc ferry tous ont
fait du bon travail que c'est
certainement pas la bonne volonté qui
leur a manqué et que à chacune des
questions qu'on se pose il avait eu de
réponse c'est à dire que lorsqu'on dit
il faut améliorer l'enseignement
professionnel ils l'ont fait et cauet et
sa coupe en sait déjà par michel rocard
avec lens et du mag ricol qui est elle
égalera réussit d'ailleurs de notre
système éducatif
par ailleurs nous voyons bien et
singulièrement depuis le drame du 7
février de cette année 2015 que
l'opinion
ces saisies enfin de la conscience du
problème soulevé aujourd'hui par la
laïcité du problème soulevé aujourd'hui
par le lien social du problème soulevé
aussi par l'idée de dation et de la
nationalité
et cependant on a l'impression que ceci
n'a pas pris sur les choses si je
faisais à bilan mais je le tiens à votre
disposition recul a été beaucoup fait
d'eux des résultats obtenus par d'autres
écoles malheureusement le constat est le
constat est plutôt des chèques de
n'assistons pas un progrès des assistons
plutôt à une régression d'analphabétisme
nous assistons également à une montée de
la violence
deux assistants une situation dans
laquelle quand deux professeurs qui eux
sont aussi plein de bonne volonté que
que leur ministre se plaignent d'être en
déshérence d'être abandonnés d'être
lâché d'être dans un des établissements
ou face à la montée de la violence et ce
n'est pas seulement dans les quartiers
dits difficiles eh bien ils leur
sentiment d'être soutenus quand ils
voient leur proviseur la proviseure leur
dis bon passait pas bien en effet
qu'est-ce qu'on fait alors que fait-on
et le proviseur vous dis alors qu'avez
vous fait bah je m'adresse au ministère
on me dit pas de vagues et du même coup
il s'en suit cette chose assez frappante
que j'entendais regrettait d'ailleurs
par luc ferry c'est que monsieur allègre
avait créé ce système cet indicateur
cigna dont on a perdu la trace qui a
indiqué une telle accélération
augmentation de la violence dans les
écoles en dépit des efforts multipliés
pour ne pas trop les faire parvenir le
précisément jusqu'à ce qui détenait les
clés de la dictateur eh bien on dit
aujourd'hui devant un mystère
c'est un mystère comment se fait-il que
malgré tant d'efforts malgré tant de
textes qu'on n'ait pas obtenu les
résultats qu'on était en droit
d'attendre
comment se fait-il que je sais bien que
les les ministres de l'éducation n'ont
jamais été très longtemps en place mais
il faut pas exagérer quand ils partent
jusqu'à nouvel ordre ils ne vivent pas
totalement leur dossier de leur bureau
d'ailleurs les archives ne leur
permettraient pas et ils ont des
successeurs qui prennent le relais
enfin faut pas non plus surestimer
le problème de la précarité de l'emploi
de ministre de l'éducation nationale
invite à bord je suis plus à leur portée
immense compassion mais pas au point où
tout de même de considérer que ça c'est
une raison suffisante pour expliquer ce
qui se passe je ne crois pas non plus
que celles en float alors où faut-il
aller regarder je crois qu'il faut aller
regarder vers précisément dans des
questions qui souvent tes et énergie de
vos rangs qu'ils sont mais seront
définies les lotions qu'est ce que par
exemple lorsque on parle de laïcité nous
parlons tous de la même chose est ce que
d'ailleurs les manifestants du 11
janvier 2015
pensez tous à la même chose merci parler
de laïcité
est-ce que également lorsque l'on parle
d'identité
dieu sait s'il y a eu des remous après
2007 2008 autour d'une grande enquête
sur l'identité nationale qui était censé
apporter des réponses sur s'est aperçue
qu'elle a soulevé plus de difficultés
car aussitôt que que de réponses car on
a vu aussi tout beaucoup de groupes à
l'intérieur d'autres sociétés dire et
mon identité temps pose pas pourquoi
serait ce la tienne tu étais là avant
mais est-ce que c'est finalement un
titre suffisant de légitimité que d'être
là avant alors il ya là un vrai problème
d'ailleurs si c'était un titre suffisant
de légitimité il y aurait pas la règle
de la prescription jusqu'à nouvel ordre
personnes en corse et présentais mon
appartement pour me dire mon grand père
en était propriétaire il a été a du bon
spolié et je viens je rentre chez moi
donc cet événement si vous les sept
composantes même de notre culture
s'inscrit en faux contre les arguments
qu'on pourrait évoquer au titre d'une
antériorité
alors qu'est-ce qu'ils vont cette notion
d'identité ses hôtes autre course est
également qui est très à la mode
aujourd'hui je me sens prêt à dessein le
mot mode c'est le mot de fraternité
alors la fraternité embrassons nous
folleville qu'est ce que ça signifie
je me rappelle le professeur carbonnier
qui lui disait avec aujourd'hui une
certaine philosophie des droits de
l'homme ont créé au bénéfice de l'autre
a droit d'exiger que vous le traitiez
comme un frère et est-ce que faut-il
pénalisés l'absence de fraternité bien
entendu non donc il y aura tout un
ensemble de sûr je voudrais essayer dans
le plus de temps que j'ai de recadrer
car madame vous avez évoqué
effectivement le fait que j'aie faire un
rapport sur l'éducation civique à
l'école et que j'insiste énormément sur
le fait qu'il faut démarrer dès la
maternelle et je crois que et s'il
définir ces quelques mots je viens
d'évoquer
ça sera une manière de répondre à la
question pourquoi faut-il commencer le
plus tôt possible a un peu donné les
rues d'ibb ans d'apprentissage civique
dès le plus jeune âge alors je vais
prendre d'abord cette notion de laïcité
oui il existe une laïcité à la française
et de laïcité à la française qu'il
ressemble à aucune autre et laïcité à la
française que pendant très longtemps nos
voisins nous envier en se disant après
tout nous n'avons pas eu l'attentât de
madrid 2020 nous n'avons pas eu
l'attentât de londres
nous nous avons nous n'avons pas eu
d'attentât d'amsterdam
hélas bien entendu nous avons été
rejoints par la violence qui
contestaient notre attachement à ce
principe de laïcité mais que faut-il
entendre par là je crois qu'il faut pas
être dupe des mots l'état laïque n'est
pas au sens propre neutre l'état laïc
neutralisent le plus possible l'espace
public
il sépare de plus possible l'espace
publique et la sphère privée je ne dis
pas évidemment un totalement le plus
possible
et ça se voit de façon très claire dans
la loi a hélas de séparation de 1905
car qu'est ce qu'elle dit elle dit la
loi la république assure la liberté de
conscience elle garantit le libre
exercice des cultes sous les seules
restrictions sous les seules
restrictions édictées ci-après dans
l'intérêt de l'ordre public et ces
restrictions sont assez claires je me
bornerai incité d'articles 26 il est
interdit de tenir des réunions
politiques dans les locaux servent
habituellement à l'exercice d'un culte
c'est clair c'est à dire qu' il n'y a
pas de confusion acceptable ou
admissibles entre locale qui a une
vocation à être l'espace public le plus
possible dégager des passions
irrationnelles au nombre desquels qu'on
les juge sévèrement ou pas la question
de pala se situe évidemment les foi
religieuse qui comporte aussi dimension
dre de raisons mais qui sont
fondamentalement tout de même différente
de l'effort vers la raison politique qui
a été dit des halles des lumières et
donc il n'est pas possible de confondre
ces deux espaces où il faut le faire le
moins possible
on va pas rasé les églises on va pas
interdire les processions l'on va les
soumettre à autorisation par exemple de
même le problème des crèches dans une
mairie j'avoue que j'aurais jamais fait
approcher avec mary qui aurait vu une
crèche
parce que seul usage et que ça s'est
toujours fait ainsi et que je connais
même pas un radical de gauche parmi mes
habits du protesté spontanément vers ça
mais à partir du moment où la question
des droits étaient posées que pouvait-on
faire on appliquer la loi
je prends également le l'habileté de la
loi debré sur l'école privée qui a été
remarquablement astucieuse
elle a dit bon nous allons continuer
soutenir un financer l'école privée dans
la mesure où effectivement il n'est pas
de liberté formelle qui dès prouve le
besoin de trouver sa consécration dans
l'exercice réel
c'est très bien mais cela va falloir
quelques temps
il ya des contraintes qui sont posées
par contrat autrement dit il ya les
lieux où le caractère propre peut
s'exprimer de l'établissement et puis
les lieux dans lesquels est bien là
règles identiques ça pose à tous et
évidemment la loi debré c'était 3 6 9
ça a été largement prolongée grâce à un
certain nombre de lois qui ont été
votées ultérieurement mais l'esprit on
est resté et je prends l'exemple de la
loi là que vous avez souhaité introduire
madame et pour moi qui ne me choque pas
du tout à partir du moment où il ya un
financement de l'état
l'état est en droit d'exiger une
neutralité de l'espace consacré à la
mission en l'occurrence celle que vous
visiez c'était celle des crèches n'ont
pas les crèches chromé dans le berry le
les crèches où on met les enfants est
effectivement des normes
bon c'était la suite logique à bon sens
de la sphère baby loup donc là je crois
que cette conception de la laïcité de
ses propres l'état de tra lise l'espace
public
pourquoi parce que nous avons une
expérience des guerres de religion
parce que à la disait quand dans sur un
trottoir de croyants qui ont des
convictions divergentes se croiser
il y a du sens parce que effectivement
si vous voulez éviter des conflits
explique ti fait pas c'est absolument
voir à laterrière de la société est bien
le seul boyard au corps ce qui est une
espèce de conversion qui fasse que
évidemment l'état et honnête homme
disait jadis ce qui était peut-être
presque mieux que l'état de droit et
parce que au moins il y avait cette
possibilité de la tolérance et la
tolérance de l'errance réciproque
faisait que effectivement on trouver des
accommodements baissé à cause bonnement
sous condition évidemment qu'on n'exige
pas de l'état qui finance la question se
pose aujourd'hui c'est très clair a
proposé aux spip et on voit très bien
que nous avons une nécessité qui est de
surveiller ce qui s'y dit ce qui s'y
fait on va pas obliger les imams à
parler français
autrement il faudrait que la science
pour tous les cours se fasse également
français et par leur anglaise ce qui
serait un problème mais du mois peut-on
s'assurer que ils utiliseront pas ces
lieux à des fins qui serait en violation
de l'article 26 il est interdit de dire
de la loi de 1905 il est interdit de
tenir des réunions politiques dans les
locaux servant habituellement à
l'exercice d'un culte
d'où toute la problématique sûr qu'elle
aura peut-être l'occasion de revenir de
la formation des imams
mais c'est évidemment pas l'état de s'en
charger on peut peut-être trouver
d'autres formules
j'aurai l'occasion d'y revenir je veux
pas excéder bon temps je vais prendre un
second un second thème 2 au thème si
vous m'y autorise et j'ai cinq minutes
aux gradés bon bon c'est la notion la
notion d'identité
cette fameuse question d'identité
d'identité c'est mieux d'être dans
l'histoire française
à partir de là révolution française
la dose sur d'identité c'est d'abord
elle repose d'abord sur un certain
nombre de vecteurs qui sont évidemment
la laïcité et qui repose sur l'éducation
c'est à dire que l'identité française
c'est à la fois celle que je me
construis évidemment par moi-même dans
laquelle du jeu imminente m'identifie à
des actes et prend la responsabilité de
ce que je suis et de ce que je fais mais
c'est d'abord l'éducation les c'est
comme ça je veux dire d'autres modèles
existent qui sont davantage qui oppose
avantage sur le sang qui refait repose
davantage sur l'ethnicité qui repose
davantage sur la religion
mais ce sont les vecteurs produit par le
système éducatif vire au permis de
construire cette nation à partir de
populations d'origine était très
différente et de revendication
d'appartenance religieuse très
différentes
alors je sais bien qu'aujourd'hui on re
découvre
et revendication d'appartenance mais
chacun sait que le phénomène
communautaire est un phénomène assez
largement et d'appartenance et tafer
domaine assez largement imaginaire au
sol d'un dense le construit il ya une
demande aujourd'hui de la société qui se
tourner vers l'état pour exiger une
reconnaissance et cette reconnaissance
voyons sans les effets eh bien je suis
désolé de le dire mais ils sont pas
heureux c'est à dire que nous assistons
à une escalade de revendication de
droits correspondant à chacune de ces
identités
je prends l'exemple d'un ami très cher
qui est le grand am actuelle avec lequel
j'ai souvent ce débat lui voudrait
absolument que les fêtes juives de
déplacent par exemple les dates du
baccalauréat
bon alors bien entendu il est c'est à
l'esprit intelligent brillant et souple
il admettrait bien des accommodements
mais enfin fondamentalement il voudrait
bien arriver à ses fins il ya les
exigences également dans les restaurants
d'école etc
franchement c'est des histoires dont on
se dit mais y at-il lieu d'en faire un
tel plat si j'ose m'exprimer ainsi
car enfin c'est absurde bon bah tiens
pas le portent pas de porc et puis voilà
un pasta le on peut prévoir une variante
dans le menu qui ne coûterait rien
absolument à personne c'est beaucoup
plus compliqué déjà quand on quand on
passe au halal car dans d'autres armes
et le corps d'être vifs pose la question
sérieusement de savoir comment on peut
s'en sortir
eh bien je ne sache pas une religion qui
ne comporte dans son principe
cette idée qu'il faut qu'elle se plie
aux pratiques aux usages d'une société
alors ce qu'on ingère ce qu'on mange et
c'est toxique analystes vous dira c'est
absolument fondamental c'est vrai sans
doute
enfin il y a toujours des alternatives
possibles et se focaliser là dessus
c'est vraiment vouloir faire un problème
politique de quelque chose qu'il a un
caractère à mon avis de golaud u10
vulgaire et subalternes non ça ne l'est
plus quand dans des banlieues entières
vous n'avez plus que des boucheries
halal
et que vous avez envie de manger de la
viande rouge
alors cette histoire donc d'identité il
faut faire attention c'est un geste
identité quand elle se réclame et se
revendique d'appartenance éthiques et
religieuses
bien entendu pas quand on a plus que la
religion ou la race on sait où ça mène
je n'insiste pas je suis prêt à y
revenir parce que je crois que ce thème
est extrêmement important et surtout il
légitime chez notre cette idée est mon
identité
qu'est-ce que tu refais c'est ce qui
s'est passé à partir de 2008 alors je
m'arrête là parce que j'étais être long
mais c'est vous indiquez un peu à d'état
d'esprit qui est le suivant je crois que
la réponse à la question initiale à
savoir comment se fait-il que que y ait
eu un échec de tous ces efforts qui ont
été faits je crois qu'il est d'abord
évidemment il
il émane d'une da durcissement de la
demande sociale en direction d'autres
conception de la laïcité que celle qui
est deux qui appartient à d'autres
cultures d'autres en direction également
de l'identité des revendications
identitaires et qui se traduisent en
terme de droit et 12 avril logique
juridique aujourd'hui qui a été
admirablement analysées par le doyen
carbonnier en particulier dans un essai
que je vous recommande droit et passion
du droit est sous-titré sous la vème
république mais ça vient de plus loin
chez nous il ya une des dérives du droit
type paraissent effectivement de plus en
plus difficile à maîtriser et il me
semble que moi qui me suis toujours
battu ce sera mon dernier mot contre les
yeux fm parce que je trouvais que
c'était le lieu de provisions
pédagogique qui était quelquefois un
tout petit peu exubérante
je me demande si aujourd'hui il faut
parvenir à un effort national à ce
niveau-là à une re création des yeux est
faible malheur à condition évidemment
que je sois titulaire de ce qu'une
fonction d'enseignant directeur parce
que les antes évidemment vous en douter
mais je crois que là il va falloir
peut-être s'occuper de la formation des
maîtres c'est pas leur bonne volonté qui
est en cause
mais c'est tout à l'ensemble sur lequel
je suis prêt à revenir devant
merci beaucoup donc ira porter va vous
poser les premières questions
jacques grosperrin merci président merci
à vous d'avoir posé le débat en tout cas
de manière très très réel je crois que
c'est important de partir de
considérations quand même philosophique
ou d'ordre dans leur moral
moi j'ai plusieurs questions donc mais
mes collègues puissent intervenir
vous avez parlé vous l'avez hills qui
sait tout à l'heure dans le cadre d'un
rapport au conseil économique social
vous aviez dit que vous avez proposé de
du cours d'éducation civique dès la
maternelle 1 dès le plus jeune âge et ma
première question que pensez vous des
annonces récentes du président de la
république du ministre de la ministre de
l'éducation nationale sa première
question
la deuxième question c'est dans une
circulaire de 1883 jules-ferry demandé
aux enseignants de parler hardiment car
ce qu'ils communiquent à l'enfant ce
n'est pas leur propre sagesse mais la
sagesse du genre humain
pensez vous que les enseignants sont
suffisamment soutenu dans ce travail qui
n'est pas directement disciplinaire et
enfin une troisième question vous avez
esquissé vous avez dit vous y reviendrez
sait mais quelle valeur devrait être
plus précisément saigne et surtout vous
avez parlé des sp selon quelle méthode
est selon k pédagogie atout redoutable
de la question parce que je vais essayer
de pas de pas être trop l'eau et de
patrons vous vous décevoir car
évidemment ce n'est pas simple ce que je
pense la proportion actuelle c'était
déjà le cas à propos de monsieur peillon
c'est que vous avez rappelé très très
bien que jules ferry et bab c'est rare
qu'on le rappelle dans sa lettre
instituteur disent parler hardiment
lorsqu'il s'agit d'un sujet fondamental
jules ferry dit aussi et c'est aussi
important ne dit rien qui soit
susceptible de froisser la conscience
d'un seul de vous aider vous même des
parents car c'est une époque on le
redoutait pas trop la présence des
parents
eh bien je pense que l'idée de jules
ferry c'était ça il faut éviter
il faut à la fois des principes et des
principes fondamentaux qui doivent être
acquis par les enfants b il faut aussi
éviter de leur inculquer ce contre quoi
tout otaries se rebelleront une morale
d'état c'est là le problème je me
rappelle que quand j'ai fait ce rapport
les médias aussitôt m'ont dit ah vous
preniez un retour à la morale à nous
renault la réforme intellectuelle et
morale
voilà bon non non il y à une logique de
la république qui est que droit et
brasles sont hétéronome ça peut pas dire
évidemment qu'on ait machiavélien 1
ça ne veut pas dire c'est du tout mais
ça veut dire que le pouvoir doit
s'arrêter de politique doit s'arrêter là
où commence en effet la jonction morale
qui applique un certain nombre de choix
qui sont des choix de valeurs et ses
choix de valeurs le problème est souvent
est aujourd'hui plus que jamais nous le
voyons la contradiction entre les
valeurs enseignées à l'école est souvent
les valeurs enseignées dans les familles
le gosse entre les deux vous en
fabriquer un petit schizophrène
alors je voudrais vous citez juste en
parallèle à la lettre aux instituteurs
du 17 novembre 1883 à textes de un peu
antérieures qui est dû à jules barni
jules barni qui a été une personnalité à
jules à la jules mais se tait s'il a
écrit à la fin du second empire c'était
un républicain résistant et il a
d'ailleurs été ensuite je crois qu'il a
fait partie de cette maison et qui a été
vu mardi le traducteur de corte
sait on a vécu jusqu'à alain renaut sur
la traduction de la raison pure par par
barney et de la raison pratique par
victor jeu pas delbos et voici ce que
disait barnier je crois que ça va
suffire à vous répondre puisque faut pas
que j'abuse de mon temps de parole que
je surveille d'abord tulle
je réduis à surveiller dès le départ
d'ailleurs alors voici ce que dit jules
mardi on commence à comprendre
aujourd'hui que la politique et la
morale ne sont pas absolument identique
le domaine de la politique et celui du
droit c'est à dire de tout ce qui peut
nous être légitimement imposé par une
contrainte extérieure
je disais tout à l'heure peut-on
contrainte d'être à être fraternel à
bord ce qu'on va me pénalisé parce que
j'ai pas été fraternelle ajouté au
règlement du droit naturel dhr antérieur
et supérieur en soit toute convention
mais qu'il faut bien fixer par des lois
positives celui des intérêts collectifs
auxquels il peut de convenir de pouvoir
par des conventions public qui
deviennent aussi des lois pour chacun de
nous et vous aurez tout le domaine de la
politique sa juridiction ne s'étend pas
au delà je dirais même que c'est grâce à
ça que la troisième république qui a
réécrit notre histoire n'a pas était
totalitaire la restreint l'espace dans
lequel la loi pouvait intervenir et elne
et c'est précisément à la disposition de
l'individu de la conscience individuelle
des choix qui n'appartiennent pas à la
société mais qui appartiennent à chacun
le reste 10 et barney c'est à dire tout
ce qui dans la morale n'est pas de droit
appartient exclusivement au fort
intérieur au domaine de la conscience
que la politique que la démocratie
particulièrement soit intéressé à
l'observation de ses devoirs qui ne
regardent que la conscience qu'elle en
favorise même l'action s'il est possible
par les moyens qui sont ressort à la
bonne heure mais elle n'a pas le droit
de les imposer par la force dont elle
dispose
lorsqu elle méconnaît la limite de sa
juridiction et qu elles empiètent sur le
domaine propre de la morale elle tombe
dans une tyrannie insupportable
elle est condamnée employés des plus
détestables moyens l'espionnage des
moeurs
l'acquisition des consciences et elle
favorise ceux qui accusent au duo monde
l'ipo cris je dois dire que d'ailleurs
les skis merveilleux dans la culture
politique française c'est que les
français supportent très bien les
vendeurs en politique je sais si nous
n'avons pas manqué maison l horaire des
hypocrites
horreur si avant d'ailleurs parfois la
tâche beaucoup plus difficile pour la
gauche parce que quand on prend 20 de
gauche aussi tu assures de contradiction
avec les principes qu'il affirme
évidemment lui tombe dessus alors donc
cette ma réponse à votre question est là
c'est à dire j'ai un peu peur
aujourd'hui que quelquefois on dérive
vers les diction la tentation des
dictées morale d'état c'était
certainement parce que j'ai voulu faire
dans ce rapport je m'endette et garder
mais on voit bien la demande sociale les
médias la presse qui veut à tout prix
vous avez la morale à droite le droit
gauche en faveur
en gros un pur pour résumer par
conséquent il s'agissait de diaboliser
d'emblée figaro et c'est peut-être aussi
une certaine réputation qu'on ne m'aura
fait sait-on jamais un sursaut alors bon
voilà alors vous votre troisième point
c'était dedans ça c'est le premier point
vos deux autres poids excusez moi alors
c'est là c'est là je crois que il ya il
faut pas être anti pédagogistes de
manière systématique
à partir du moment où on n'est pas
habilité à dire ce qui est bien aussi et
mal d'ailleurs madame vallaud-belkacem
il a fait allusion bon il faut peut-être
donner au moins aux enfants et dès le
plus jeune âge la conscience du fait
qu'ils sont capables de distinguer entre
le bien et le mal
ça c'est pas la même chose et il le faut
par des moyens pédagogiques sur quel
j'assisterai par b qui sont beaucoup de
2,2 mètres de maternelle savent le faire
ou de maîtresses de maternelle
savent le faire mais il faut une
formation tout à fait particulière à ça
et il faut aussi formation la
psychologie des groupes
il faut que les gosses après de les uns
par rapport aux autres les rapports de
civilité ça m'amènerait loin d'ailleurs
cette question là parce que l'histoire
de la civilité très intéressante à
observer les rapports de civilité on
s'aperçoit que c'est les salons se sont
souvent aussi les les associations les
corporations les syndicats qui ont créé
des règles de civilité en quelque sorte
pour se protéger contre l'intrusion du
pouvoir
ce sont des codes non écrit des règles d
apprentissage de la vie en société
auquel nous devons précisément d'être
des civilisés et si vous voulez plus on
veut mettre les rapports de civilité
dans des textes écrits plus on amène
l'intervention évidemment du pouvoir
plus on amène la pénalisation de la
société et on arrive à des situations
tout à fait caricatural c'est pour ça
que par exemple s'ils ont d'abord des
problèmes de la langue que je vous
dirais que d'enjeux dans cette logique
là parler le français le mieux possible
c'est une politesse vis-à-vis des autres
une politesse vis-à-vis de soi-même
c'est du temps de gagné aussi parce
qu'on se comprend peut-être plus vite
c'est aussi des références à tout un
passé culturel à tout un bagage partager
à partir du moment où on essaie de
mettre sa part écrit moi j'ai été assez
jd je dois le dire par la loi qui est
une loi qui veulent une faire parler
français pour éviter de contraventions
on ne parle pas français pour éviter de
contraventions on n'est pas si vide dans
le métro pour éviter de contraventions
etc etc alors ce propos va vous paraître
ultra libérale que celle où il vit de la
république et au diable quand je dis en
diable évidemment ses vis-à-vis d'abord
contrarier ici aucun croyant alors voilà
deux add mort de réponse alors c'est en
effet des conduites et j'en avais fait
un en-avant terre je crois qu'il faut
faire comprendre aux grosses que la être
responsable c'est c'est une condition de
de la liberté que quand on prend un
risque il faut assumer les conséquences
il faut pas tout le temps demandé à la
maîtresse d'avoir prévenu prévu le
risque comme la société nous fait vivre
au quotidien parce que on nous
infantilise leur apprendre à distinguer
entre l'espace publique et la sphère
privée ça c'est toi le tient le bien or
écrit d'une certaine façon les bills de
rousseau si vous voulez enfin j'exagère
je pousse un peu mais c'est un petit peu
cette cette idée là ces idées là qu'il
faut qu'il faut faire progresser et puis
alors bien entendu la langue il faut
leur parler avec un certain degré
d'exigence est le plus tôt possible la
lecture l'écriture on sait très bien que
ce qui n'est pas acquis et dès les
premières années est d'autant plus
difficile à rattraper plus tard on a des
statistiques là dessus qu'ils sont
évidentes et le problème évidemment
c'est que une thèse que j'avais combattu
remet en mai 68 et je le regrette
cette de bourdieu et passeron sur les
héritiers se trouve aujourd'hui vérifier
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui
effectivement les ghosts bibliothèque à
la maison qu'ils entendent parler un bon
français jésus etc etc
bon évidemment ils ont une espèce de
pour eux le problème la maternelle se
pose peut-être moi et encore je ne suis
pas très sûr quand j'entends parler des
générations a priori issus de milieux
favorisés
ayant accédé à des diplômes qui peuvent
être l'agrégation et chez lesquels on se
dit qu'il faudrait pas vouloir prendre
le parfum de la grammaire et
l'orthographe
enfin bon ça c'est le voeu d être
désagréable envers personne
merci beaucoup
chers collègues donc on va prendre
plusieurs questions monsieur longuet
merci madame la présidente j'ai deux
questions pratiques non une question
pratique aucune des pratiques d'ailleurs
une question d'apparence simple un
gérard l'un slama où ils pouvoir à
l'éducation nationale et la deuxième où
elle pouvoir l'éducation nationale la
deuxième qui avec votre expérience et
votre
pratique des différents ministres et je
suis je partage votre sentiment leur
bonne volonté qui n'opèrent pas qu'ils
n'opèrent pas jusqu'au bout
deuxième question est plus une
reste et il n'ya pas vous avez évoqué
quelle est la légitimité de l'identité
être là avant nous dit non ça c'est pas
possible parce que sinon il y aurait une
que vos l'antériorité sorte de
prescription qui font que tout le monde
peut-être français je partage totalement
ce point de luxe juste une question les
valeurs républicaines
on peut en avoir deux approches dire il
ya la table de la loi c'est la
déclaration des droits de l'homme du 26
août 1789 et moïse est descendu et nous
a donnée notable et en lettres il ya une
autre approche qui est de dire que la
révolution française est le produit de
notre histoire et des compromis des
expériences heureuses et malheureuses
que nous avons connus aller en gros pour
simplifier depuis le baptême de clovis à
ce moment là on a une profondeur et je
pense que si l'antériorité ne légitime
pas tous les droits
refus récuser l'héritage nous appauvrit
nécessairement et il fait disparaître
notre identité je veux savoir où se
trouvait pour vous l'équilibré était
trop long ça pas cher président je
regardais s'il y avait d'autres
questions comme ça on aura jean claude
carle ouimet et des résultats qui sont
soit insuffisants voire qu'ils d'être
qui se détériorait ce cas pas un
problème j'ai à dire de méthodes etc
tant votre exposé la réponse y ait tant
d'efforts tant de textes est ce qu'on va
résoudre les problèmes de l'éducation
uniquement ou seulement par les textes
est ce que j'allais dire il faudrait pas
au contraire peut-être favorisé
pardonnez moi d'être à brute passée la
culture de la circulaire à la culture du
contrat entre les différents acteurs
la deuxième
de la deuxième question vous avez dit
qu'il fallait commencer très tôt
j'y souscris tout à fait ainsi mais
encore faut-il que commencé très tôt à
ces notions de laïcité le modèle de
morale encore faut-il que nos jeunes
soient capables d'assimiler ces données
or on sait qu'aujourd'hui 30 à 40% des
jeunes qui rentrent en collège ne
maîtrise pas les fondamentaux et madame
la ministre s'attaque réforme du collège
pourquoi pas mais que c'est pas le
maillon est ce que ça n'est pas le
maillon précédent c'est-à-dire celui du
primaire et le premier cycle des pré
apprentissage tel qu'il était mis dans
la loi de 89 de monsieur jospin 1 que le
coeur du problème de l'eau jour d'hui et
à ce niveau là voilà je suis moi je ne
maîtrise pas bien là solo alors la
réponse à gérard longuet mon dieu comme
il a raison bien sûr bien sûr que le
pouvoir le pouvoir aujourd'hui dans
notre société il peut pas être incarné
par un seul homme c'est l'évidence il
peut pas être incarnée par le chef d'une
administration
il ya eu un effort par exemple pour
pousser porte et je crois que gérard il
ya été pour quelque chose vous pousser
l'administration à se réformer
ça s'appelait la lolf je crois bon cette
fameuse loi d'orientation de la loi de
finances qui est arrivé finalement à ce
que les administrations créé à leurs
côtés des organes censés d évaluer comme
nous n'avons qu'une culture de
l'évaluation ça n'a pas donné grand
chose dans l'opinion et je crois pas que
les effets de la lolf malheureusement
était à la hauteur de ce qu'on attendait
autrement dit la réforme de la terrière
de ce fait d'armes forteresse
anthropique qu'est l'éducation nationale
je crois qu'effectivement les évolutions
vers l'autonomie mais dans le cadre de
programmes nationaux ça il faut pas mais
alors la lâcher d'un pouce
là dessus et deux programmes je dirais
qui doit-il doivent être fixées par des
instances ne relevant pas du vote
parlementaire je veux dire par là que on
a vu ce qui s'est passé lorsque des
parlementaires ont voulu apporter une
modification program qui était vraiment
pas très méchante qui était de rappeler
le rôle notamment positif de la présence
de la france dans les colonies notamment
positive bon ça soulevé un tollé et moi
même j'ai 10 il n'appartient pas aux
parlementaires pouvoir politique de
décider des programmes si non alors où
va t'on où va-t-on donc la question donc
du pouvoir
il faut prendre de plus en plus en
compte la nécessité de mettre des bêtes
copé temps et de les soutenir
là où ils sont face à leurs élèves
ça va pas au delà d'ailleurs ça veut
dire c'est là que je reviens à mon idée
qui n'en est pas une mais deux la
formation des maîtres est d'état est
indispensable
on ne peut plus aujourd'hui on parle de
former les immeubles c'est bien gentil
il faut former nos maîtres je suis
désolé de le dire ainsi c'est pas du
tout qui manque de formation mais il
faut coordonner entre eux quand même
leur donner les éléments qui leur
permettent de maîtriser cette situation
parce que ce que fait le b10 ce que fait
le pouvoir est en général plutôt
raisonnable je n'aime pas qu'à ministre
de l'éducation et de l'enseignement
supérieur 10
je ne veux pas entendre parler
d'excellence ça je trouve ça assez je ne
sais pas qui a pu dire ça mais ça je
crois que c'est une erreur parce que là
le pouvoir peut jouer un rôle de blocage
particulièrement dangereux mais
c'est à pouvoir médiatique c'est
l'opinion qui va réagir
ça n'est pas vraiment quelque chose qui
va bouger dès les structures je pense en
effet que la pour 7,6 localisation du
pouvoir faute foucaldien le pouvoir
aujourd'hui départ concentrée uniquement
entre les mains d'un homme miracle qui
resterait là je rappellerai que en 1934
il y avait l'homme le plus célèbre en
france que léon blum salué comme le
grand républicain par axe et lance qui
était le maréchal pétain avait souhaité
détenir le portefeuille de l'éducation
nationale
bon voilà effectivement il ya toujours
un rêve comme ça de réformer la genèse
de la conduire et de lui indiquer la
voie
bon qui est aujourd'hui quand même je
crois que dès midi sans nouveaux courts
a battu y en a même un qui avait décrit
comment peut-on être ministre ce qui a
dit clairement que il en était revenu
alors l'autre question bien sûr la
profondeur alors c'est une chose de dire
les lumières la révolution française
construisent à projets qui lorsqu'on
regarde les textes qu'on va de 2 2 que
de condorcet qu'on lit de prêt russo et
d'une cohérence magnifique du
d'intelligence magnifique prévoit les
réponses aux objections
et quand on dit que la raison
révolutionnaire est à l'origine ça je me
suis toujours insurgé contre ceux là
du bolchevisme et du totalitarisme c'est
faux et benjamin constant l'admirable
l'a exprimé dans son texte sur qui
restait célèbre sans doute pour ça sur
la liberté selon les anciens et les
modernes c'est que les modernes ont
voulu avoir à la fois le beurre et
l'argent du beurre
c'est à dire la liberté l'autonomie des
individus et d'un autre côté de la
communion du lien social par dessus tout
ça au prix d'ailleurs de la liberté de
chacun et ça ça a été la terreur la
terreur ça a été plaqué du communautaire
sur de l'individuel c'était exactement
ça donc c'est idiot de dire c'est la
raison c'est à dévoiement de l'arrêt
ce n'est pas du tout la même chose donc
là il y a eu quand même ce grand projet
mais c'est un projet pour plusieurs
siècles
c'est idiot vous allez dire que je parle
comme un communiste qui vous dit bien
sûr l'état liquide
alors enfin bon d'ailleurs ça peut être
sympathique chez q quelquefois quand
c'est badiou qui s'en parle cet argument
mais non c'est un projet pour rallier
plusieurs siècles et ce projet c'est un
individu émancipé autonome responsable
et solidaire
voilà bon ça veut pas dire qu'il n'ya
pas des dérives que dominique schnapper
admirablement décrite d'ailleurs dans
son dernier livre où elle monte les
dérives la démocratie trop d'égalité du
à l'égalité trop de communautés et de et
de bien social lui et c'est bon donc je
n'assiste pas sur ces dérives vous les
connaissez tous je vous vois au pid et
drogba le en revanche la culture c'est
une autre affaire
la tradition culturelle s'est pas
seulement le champ du politique
la tradition culturelle c'est la langue
est derrière la langue il ya toute une
histoire
or ce que j'observe et pour répondre à
gérard longuet c'est que il ya cette
merveille dans l'histoire française que
de l'un puis la chanson de rolland au
moins ce sont des textes littéraires qui
sur les référents transmis dans notre
système éducatif
donc seulement pour illustrer la langue
mais pour nous parler de la france
souvent d'ailleurs des on se fait élire
en parlant bia de la france je vous fais
remarquer lien c'est au moins aussi
important que d'avoir des idées et cette
construction
cette construction de notre histoire
elle repose fondamentalement sur la
littérature bien sûr c'est il ya de tout
dans notre littérature
il ya des rebelles il ya des apostats il
ya des c b il y à une transmission
extraordinaire de quelque chose de
fondamental qui est que la littérature
par définition et des libres elle ne
peut exister que libre il n'y a pas de
littérature totalitaire
quel que soit le contre-exemple de
boulgakov et je crois que ça cette cette
idée si vous voulez qui a été cher à
coups de bérat
de l'univers romanesque qui nous montre
l'individu pas nécessairement contre les
pouvoirs parfois en marge des pouvoirs
mais prenant en charge en tout cas du
point de vue de la liberté des problèmes
de la société a laissé régulièrement
tous nos princes médusé impuissant et
souvent dépendants c'est à dire que la
construction centralisée de la france
par des princes s'est accompagnée de
leur part du souci d'avoir quelqu'un à
eux l'épée à un espace à l'autre le
temps à l'autre la durée à l'écrivain la
transmission l'héritage le 14 sa commode
quand même les taux d'abandon racines
janséniste
quand on y pense ou de ou de ceux la
fontaine qui s'était compromis
horriblement avec fougue et etc
autrement dit l'écrivain a toujours usé
vraiment abusé de cette liberté là mais
c'est une merveille
c'est le trésor de notre vie culture et
de notre tradition voilà ma manière à
moi de répondre qui n'est pas j'espère
et hypocrite à cette question du bien
sûr qu'il ya eu et n'avons viala
d'ancien régime
il ya eu un bon la question de savoir si
le 89 et une rupture ou pas oui c'est
une rupture c'est aussi un aboutissement
sas et tocqueville
david est persuadé que cette
centralisation de devait aboutir qu'à ça
cela dit il parle et il s'exprime lors
d'un moment il ya l'expérience du
premier empire one homme de génie en
attirer en effet quelque chose qui
aurait pu évoluer autrement n'oublions
pas que les débuts de la révolution
française c'était le vote municipal
s'était d'élection des juges etc etc
ce n'était pas tout à fait donc
l'héritage il y avait une réaction
contre l'ancien régime c'est-à-dire au
four le holisme certaine conception
holiste de la société je veux dire
englobante de la société qui avait été
le propre évidemment de l'ancien régime
blue ont été assignés en quelque sorte à
son appartenance
c'est pour ça que me méfie à petit plus
du concept d'appartenance qui a été je
sais
parfois loué à cette même place
voilà le ce que je ce que je dirais
alors on peut aller plus loin en tout
cas cette notion quand même c'est
dimension affective de la perception de
la culture française ça oui peut-être
labour de la france qui est qui et dans
la chanson de rolland et cette idée d'un
pays généreux tu parles bon etc etc
mais il ya une construction la belgique
parce que elle a été transmise et tous
les les archétypes de notre littérature
demeure vivant dans les consciences
chacun d'entre vous nous se prend pour
un père goriot par exemple par rapport à
ses enfants
je ne dirais pas que nos compagnes se
prête pour emma bovary
mais en tout cas on d'art on vit
constamment avec ses références là et ce
qui est mon souci aujourd'hui jusqu'à
peut-être houellebecq sait-on jamais
c'est que depuis quelques temps depuis
j'irai milieu du xxème siècle enfin là
depuis le débat sartre camus a et le
nouveau robot etc
on a une déprise une espèce de
séparation de corps entre le pouvoir
d'un côté entre la société française
d'un côté et ses écrivains de l'autre
alors ils partent comme modiano vers
l'intériorité comme le clézio qui alors
lui de plus en plus concrètement s'en va
vers les tropiques et et le seuil du jeu
que sais-je
et on a de plus en plus aujourd'hui des
grands écrivains c'est pas ça la
question
mais qui se détache de notre époque et
d'ailleurs je viens d'évoquer le cas où
elles bec
c'est intéressant de voir que son roman
subissions manifeste à l'égard de son
temps une des prises et a mépris qu'ils
auraient même choqué montherlant le mois
méprisante nos écrivains c'est tout à
fait intéressant ça c'est à dire que
c'est je pense pas que ça puisse durer
mais il ya quand même quelque chose qui
ne va plus entre
d'autres pays c'est et ses écrits va
peut-être aussi parce que blues en
perdons la transmission la mémoire
évidemment évidemment bien sûr bien sûr
ça c'est évidemment dommage des langues
anciennes
je serai pas le dernier à déplorer c'est
évident d'abord parce qu'il faut bosser
pour ça donc c'est le seul truc c'est
que en fait aujourd'hui de plus en plus
alors en maternelle un ne pas compris un
moment il faut qu'il ya tant pour le
ludique et haletant pour le travail au
dos on ne fait pas travailler en jouant
voilà donc je ferai deux donnent eux ça
marche pas voilà merci beaucoup
une question de alors que tout petit
alors merci madame le jourda et madame
32 vous avez parlé me fut le professeur
donc de notre registre culturel commun
mais malheureusement je crois que notre
registre de référence et tout ce que
vous avez évoqué est quelque peu en
perdition il ya une rupture de la chaîne
des transmissions
vous avez évoqué bon la laïcité je n'y
reviendrai pas mes collègues savent ici
que c'est un général la question que je
pose la définition de la laïcité ne vous
avez parfaitement donc fait part des
doutes qui rejoignent donc les miens ma
question sera vous ai parlé de la
formation des maîtres
je n'y reviendrai pas et vous avez-vous
évoqué la formation des imams et vous
avez dit au détour d'une phrase que vous
aviez peut-être des idées là-dessus
pourriez-vous nous en faire part veut
dire sur la la question de monsieur le
sénateur qui me disait que effectivement
bon 30 à 40% des enfants arrivent sans
avoir effectivement le niveau de faire
ma formation suffisant et nécessaire et
et vivent par conséquent avec une
extrême difficulté leur intégration dans
d'autres sociétés
je suis absolument persuadé que c'est
une des explications de la violence le
camp vous n'avez pas les beaux quand
vous n'avez pas les mots pour le dire
c'est assez talentueux america
d'ailleurs qui a admirablement expliqué
ça c'est herman melville dans dans son
big band bill budd data gros balourd qui
est accusée injustement il veut se
défendre pour se défendre comme il a des
points c'est énergique il cogne sur
celui qui l'a dénoncé ils le tuent et
par conséquent il est pendu parce que
c'est la loi dure de la marine c'est le
dot d'ailleurs un des plus beaux poèmes
de la langue anglaise qui était
admirablement huille en musique par
benjamin britten et c'est vrai c'est à
dire quand vous n'avez pas des mots et
bien souvent d'ailleurs les sociologues
à la lys à la violence dans dit dans le
temps dans les banlieues c'est ça il
m'est arrivé un jour de traiter des
voyous de culture bis casse de
cucurbitacées je cours en corse était là
c'était là la sete d'atmosphère
d'arletty ils se sont dit que je
désinvolte et le graph banc dans leur
essence même
alors bien sûr mais alors j'en viens là
à ce problème effectivement qui est qui
est lourd qui est extrêmement difficile
pour ça qu'il faut commencer le plus tôt
possible
alors que les les les le problème la
formation des des imams et bien souvent
ils sont à peu près pas très
alphabétisés pas très très fort ils ont
une lecture du coran
je vois par la fondation pour
l'innovation politique vient de se
donner un mal de chien à sortir dit kai
est admirable expliquant que le pourquoi
pas d'ailleurs aucune on peut faire une
défense illustration de toutes les
religions en ces termes les religions
ratp comme le 10 janvier la religion
d'amour de tolérance et de paix bon
malheureusement dans les faits c'est pas
exactement ce qui se passe alors si on
veut s'en assurer si on veut essayer
précisément de de fer que le l'effort
qui a été fait par le
la fondation pour l'innovation politique
de des lectures en effet du coran qui
soit constructive et orienté vers la
modernité
c'était jusqu'à présent ce qui avait
sauvé la tunisie d'ailleurs d'avoir des
personnalités exceptionnelles qui avait
précisément même d'ailleurs le patron
des latins qui est remarquablement
intelligent et et qui avait su quand
même opérer ce mouvement
la seule réponse à ça et je crois qu'il
faut on ne peut pas faire autre bon on
donne en effet au dispense des cours aux
imams ça on peut le faire
la respectant ce fait la licité à la
française juste comme ça on va falloir
expliquer leur propre religion
c'est pas le rôle de l'état alors une
idée qui avait été développé je trouvais
pas sainte
c'était de créer une fondation une
formation qui serait effectivement
indépendante de l'état mais à
l'intérieur de l'école de laquelle il y
aurait un contrôleur financier à
commissaire du gouvernement etc qui
surveillerait le fonctionnement de cette
fondation chargé précisément d'assurer
pour son compte
la formation des imams c'est une
solution compatible avec la loi de 1905
à laquelle je pense qu'il ne faut pas
toucher c'est me permets de vous dire
parce que si on commence à toucher à ça
comme toujours d'esparros dit on va
essayer d'améliorer et puis on ne
contrôle plus l'édifice mais en revanche
j'ai peut-être une adaptation possible
dans cette direction là je crois qu'il
ya eu un premier ministre qui avait
tenté de quitter ville pas je crois
qu'il y avait tenté de s'engager dans
cette direction là y en avait parlé
on avait parlé avec claude bébéar qui
était un peu son conseiller sur ces
questions là puisque il cherchait à
recruter dans la diversité et je
trouvais que cette idée était bonne j'ai
regretté qu'elle n'ait pas été
poursuivie
je vous remercie beaucoup je pense que
le temps imparti sauf si c'est une
petite petite question
c'est le professeur ma question est la
suivante vous avez parlé de la place
fondamentale de l'enseignant dans
l'école aujourd'hui on sait que les
heures de cours sont sont moindres
devant les élèves dans la classe
ce professeur ma question est la
suivante ne pensez vous pas que cela
n'est pas suffisant
la présence de l'enseignant uniquement
dans la classe devant ses élèves
oui vous savez j'ai pas la maîtrise du
budget on peut pas dominer le drame vous
savez dans notre société c'est que bon
les profs sont pas très gâté pour pas
pâtir ils n'ont pas toujours les
satisfactions d'amour propre et que bien
souvent ceux qui se mobilisent sont pas
nécessairement les plus laïcs les plus
républicains
c'est un vrai problème et on est
confronté aujourd'hui dans la société
française
les médias fonctionnent uniquement comme
ça
toute voix qui émet un son différent
d'abord la différence c'est devenu
valeur en soi respecter la différence
c'est formidable bien sûr il faut la
respecter mais alors faire valeur de ces
différents sous prétexte que c'est une
différence
le ca sert bol je trouve que c'est un
peu abusé mais donc vous avez dans les
médias ne connaissent plus que ça donc
on entend les voix les plus extrêmes
il ya un vrai problème internet la télé
vous prend une parole complètement
marginal une affaire complètement
secondaire je voulais tout à l'heure
l'histoire des réfectoires et de la
viande un réfectoire et puis vu le flop
au milieu du salon
quand c'était quand la télé il est coté
dans le salon et ben non sur votre
bientôt sur votre montre quand vous
regarderez leurs hôtes vous donnera pas
leur d'ailleurs
je comptais plus du tout où se trouvait
leur vous trouverez ce qu'il ya de pire
dans le pays alors c'est un peu ça le la
question si vous voulez la médiatisation
de sa société c'est la loi dalo soldes
bonsoir olsson qui a montré très bien
comment ben même tout syndicaliste c'est
bien s'il veut avoir des gens qui
viennent et est obligée d'offrir des
billets de tombola
sinon bah il y aura